uh thank you for your introduction uh
i'm happy to present the results
uh from this design and the from a blind
snip array for uh cattle
so first i want to give you a background
because in
probably not all of you are familiar
with cattle breeding and what's going on
on cattle breeding today
so everything in cattle breeding relies
on artificial insemination that means
desires have daughters across hertz and
based
on this structure you are able to
estimate added
kinetic values for the cyrus
which means we're using linear mixed
models and we're trying to estimate
the additive genetic value so we are
trying to correct the phenotype
basically the phenotype which is
basically recorded on farm level
by any environmental effects
to get the additive genetic value and
that's what we're
dealing with in catalytic breeding so we
use it we are using now these
so-called traditional breeding values uh
in any genomic selection model so we're
using them and
try to estimate so-called snip effects
for
uh we're estimating those snip effects
using a
genome white spread marker
map and we are not dealing or we're not
trying to answer the question who is or
which is the causative variant
so we are trying to spread over the map
over the whole genome and try to
estimate the snip effects which is
subsequently used in uh
for the to protect the young animals um
because the genomic ebvs
the so-called genomic ebvs are more
accurate than the pedigree
ebv's for the young animals so
this is the basic scheme in cata
breeding today
we have this scheme in switzerland since
2011
we have been using for this routinely
commercial available chips so far
and last year we have decided to move to
move one step further and design our
first
custom chip
so the second background which is
necessary for this talk
is a national project so far since 2011
the cattle breeders have been setting up
a large-scale genotype
archive they have been genotyping
intensively young animals
to select and to use them
in in their breeding scheme so we have
now a large-scale genotype archive which
can be used for
additional work and for for example
for uh screening of specific hypotypes
where we see
a missing or reduced homozygosity so
windows where we see a deviation from
hardy weinberg
equilibrium so we did this uh screening
uh in all of our four main populations
i forgot to introduce they are bronze
fist
the dual proposed breeds organelle
bronzie and cemental
i'm not able to present any results um
from the
from this project in this talk today but
if you're
interested in feel happy and go back uh
to my
eap presentation uh last year in ghent
so these uh two background slides i have
to give you
and inside this national project we have
been generating
uh whole genome sequence data um and we
are
now interested or before the chip design
we were interested
in to get a large number of newly
detected
variants genotyped in the populations
so what were the aims and the
requirements for the chip
there was one main goal it was we wanted
to have
a single array which meets all of our
needs
so this array had to fit and had to be
compatible with
historical genotype data in terms of
everything so it had to be it had to
enable
each check each monitoring
pipeline which has been done before
it should be a or it had to be
uh compatible with the known recessive
traits
so we are uh the breeders asked for uh
specific traits mainly recessive traits
called known from the omnia database
and we wanted to genotype
the large number of newly detected
variants under the umbrella of the
routine
genotyping platform
are sending up the samples and we want
to screen them
or to use these samples to screen our
newly detected variants
in our station and of course
last but not least thing had to be
highly efficient
in terms of the workflow and also in
terms of the cost
especially let me mention that we had
quite a high number of new markers we
wanted
to genotype and to screen in our
populations
what were the milestones uh towards this
new chip
so in winter 2018-19 we had
uh we have started everything
and we had some international calls with
the labs and
the companies and technologies
and at the end of the winter we have
taken the decision to move forward to
the axiom
genotyping platform a couple of months
later
so in july 2019 we were able to finish
uh the array which we now call a swisco
array
i'm going to present it in detail
further on but it's basically a 300k
array where we combine 100k
archive markers together with more than
200
no new newly detected markers
in from october 2019 till january 2020
so more or less three or four months we
were busy uh to what
so quite a long time but this was
necessary because
we have clearly a match between the
newly
generated genotype data and based on for
us it's a new technology
it had to fit perfectly and had to
enable everything
which was known before in our pipeline
so we were looking at the concordance
towards the illumina
phenotype archive we were looking at the
repeatability
and last but not least uh switzerland is
part
depending on breed on several
international
genotyping plot platforms
so mainly the holstein is a member of
the cdcb
exchange and the bronze versus member of
the interball exchange
so we had to run through a international
validation
as well at the end in january 2020
we were able to go live and submit the
first
routine samples being genotyped on the
chip
so a slide about the chip design
um basically as i said initially
we are combining archive markers so
these are the markers that have been
genotyped already before with the
commercial
available chips they are of course
selected on genomic level
we are combining them with the whole set
of new markers shown in the chart here
on the slide in black
or in gray and these new markers can be
divided into two sections
on the one side they are markers
from the regions that came out from the
project of the haplotype screening
so there we selected any marker
independent from any variant effect
prediction but
we added this section a third
section shown in the middle of the slide
and we selected on genomic level so
independently from the regions from the
haplotype
screening on genomic level you selected
protein-changing variants
independently from any of the protein
being affected setting up an
archive of the protein changing variants
in the swiss
cattle breeds in the subsequent
genotyping
in terms of the validation so what did
we
look at when we were busy with the
validation steps
um basically we were looking at the
concordance towards the illumina
genotype data so that means
the validations has been genotyping
had been genotyped before with the
historical
commercial available chips we have been
genotyping
the validation samples twice so we were
able to look at the repeatability
inside of our swiss cow chip we were
looking at the sex check
we were looking at the the results from
the causal variants
we had some cnvs also on the chip
also apart from the causal variants and
last but not least
we were looking at the parentage testing
parentage testing on genome-wide level
uh for which we are using for
the touch for the parents and on isaac
marker level
which is used for uh the testing of um
specific parents
so i don't want to load you with some we
speak with big numbers or large
uh slides but then in the end we ended
up in a repeatability and
as well as an a concordance towards the
archive
genotype data above 99
we had a reliable sex check with a
reliable search for parents
we had the parentage test so validated
and we had
validated the known causal variants and
as well
we were able to pass the international
chip validation at the cdcb
so coming now to the data what kind of
data or what's the
how many samples do we have now a
genotype on this chip
as i said we started in january we have
a clear seasonal effect in swiss carving
so uh swiss carving mostly occur
in autumn so we had this bunch that uh
some of
our carvings were not genotyped since
they were born before
but however we have till today more than
10 000
genotype samples on this chip
and they are coming mainly from brown
swiss
and holstein and subsequently by
by the dual proposed breeds of course
the numbers are representative
for the site population
the swiss cattle in total
so let's um let's
now have a look at the results
and i started the results focusing on
some
selected recessive traits um and
in terms of the receptor traits we have
two types
those that were known before and that
the genotype before
and the second group of recessive traits
uh they uh that were published before or
not known before
we have been submitting the array and we
did not have previous genotypes
and i'm going to show you four examples
here
the first one uh the so called our deck
is a the generation of the retina and
the eye
published in 2016 so before we have been
submitting the array
but it was never included in our chips
before
so we were not aware of any um frequency
of any early frequency in our
populations
the second one is a male fertility
related
variant it came into the essay based on
the personal communication on national
novel
published in the autumn of 2020
is highly frequent in bronzers for
example
and the last one the last two records so
so called oh1 or hh6
they have been published
um they have been identified after we
have been submitting
uh the array but they entered into the
earth
with the genomic section of protein
changing variants since the first one is
a moderate impact variant and the second
one hh6
is a high impact variant so these are
two examples
about the the gain um or about the
benefit
uh from from the selection here from
this
variant uh section here
um we were aware that most of
a large number of the those new variants
that we have
that we have been detecting in our
project are probably false positives
so we see this when we look at the early
frequency distribution we see a clear
different pattern in terms of the
protein changing variants
for the when we compare it to the
archive markers so lots of them
are fixed see this they have allele
frequency zero or one
however in the median section of each
population
uh bar plot you see that there's quite a
large number of um
variants that show segregation for
in our national populations
um when we look at the quality criteria
uh so i start with the
call rate in our more than 10 000
genotype the samples now we see a
extremely high core rate
almost all of the protein changing
variants i'm
only focusing on them on the slide as
well
are called higher than 95 percent
and you see the same high quality
results when you look at the mantle
and the mendelian errors on the protein
changing variants
so in total we have almost 50k
protein changing variants genotype on
this chip where we don't see any
mendelian error and the distribution of
the
other markers and number of mendelian
errors is shown
um on the on the bar plot on the right
part let me come now to the
results from the hardy weinberg
equilibrium we tested each variant
of our genotypes in terms of the any
deviation significant deviation from
hardy weinberg equilibrium
and we see a population specific picture
so we see several hundreds of
variants that show significant divine
significant deviation from
hardy-weinberg equilibrium
however we see a number of 44 markers
that
are common across the populations in
terms of the significant hardy weinberg
equilibrium
and this will be for sure a project or
this will be analyzed now in detail
what's going on there i have to say that
cannot be the case due to the some
parentage issues because
markers that have more than
two percent of million errors are
excluded from this analysis
last but not least um i want to give you
a forecast and the focus is the third
area i want to touch
it's the accuracy of genomic prediction
and this is mainly
of the main topic or the the main goal
then by the genotype we want to achieve
a higher accuracy of genomic prediction
for the young animals though the yeah
the prediction
um the validate the reliability of the
pre-selection should be should be high
this is work which is still ongoing so
i'm not able to present any results of
the gain of this new chip
in terms of this part of the results
however
it is known from literature that it is
beneficial to include
um real causative variants instead of
just putting a genome right selected
dense marker set in and use them in
genomic predictions so what did we
to get an idea about the benefit from
the from this chip here
we imputed the whole genotype archive
and i forgot to mention this in the
beginning for branch physics for example
we have 80
000 of genotype samples till today
we imputed the whole archive um
using f impute software onto our swiss
cloud density
and then repeat it or run singleton
progression models
where we correct it for any
stratification using the
genomic relationship matrix
in order to identify uh qtl
regions so regions where we see a major
gene effect
towards a trait a trait which is
routinely available from routine
phenotype recording in cattle
so fertility traits birth traits
carcass traits and milk production
traits of course
and we compared the results from this
from this um single snip progression
models uh with
the results from the singleton
progression models from the
routine uh system
so uh to get uh to give you an idea
where the the qtls are located uh
in terms of the chromosome and the
region of the chromosome just uh
i wanted to to highlight um
the environ uh the red dots on this uh
genome
picture but the most important thing is
that we compare now
the results from both singles and
progression models
and we look in each uh gmos in each qtl
region
whether the mostly most significantly
associated snip
is the same or whether it's a different
one
and you see in the third
column from left and that there's quite
a high number of
qtl regions where
the snip the mostly the most
significantly associated
snip is a different one compared to the
results
from the from the routine model
finally a proof of concept uh there are
some few qtl's in cattle breeding known
uh where we where we know the real
causative role of the variant and one
example is the
uh the d gut the moderate impact variant
of d dgat
k 232 towards a
variant and in fact we see this
we have this variant on the swiss cod
chip but we don't have this
variant on our routinely genotype
archive
and what we see here is we see it's the
mostly
most significantly associated snip
in that region with the trade fat yield
so that's a nice proof of concept
it was somehow expected but however it's
nice that we have uh been
achieving this result there's a second
example and this example comes
more or less from a different the
background
it's the last row in this table
it's the loss of function mutation in
the apob
gene which is responsible for the
recessive disorder cholesterol
deficiency known in holstein
and we see here we have been identifying
basically this region
uh sqtl uh towards a trait uh called
rearing success uh heifer period sway so
this is the
the rearing success or you call it
building loss during um
rear rearing the the cow as
the heifer uh in routine in the routine
system we have been um
seen the qtl on chromosome 11 at
80 megabase pairs it's quite a big shift
by more than two megabytes press what we
see
uh um also on chromosome 11 so the
the loss of function mutation is the
variant
in that area which is the as the shows
the strongest
significant association so a second
proof of concept but the different
um background where it comes from
and all the other rows in this table
are variants where we see
that the variant or the mostly
significant
the most significantly associated region
in that it was the trade is different
one but it was never published before
so in summary um we had
a let's call it a straightforward error
designed
by a lock together with the colleagues
of them fisher
namely fabian grunky who was a big help
in all those questions during the error
validation it was in
intensive lots of video calls
already between the lab the genotyping
lab
which is efn in germany between fabian
and between us
but we ended up in i think general
positive results
we had to do some changes compared to
what we were doing
before in our in-house processes and in
our
in-house pipelines we
had to learn that
we have to keep the sample sample
throughput
throughput under control because um the
genotype
the cisco error is in genotype in 96
format
so depending on the facilities at the
lab
you have to keep the samples shipped
weekly
under control but in the end
we ended up at high quality and very
promising results for
further analysis and i showed some
hopefully in the slide what we are doing
now
we have been in summer 2020 we have been
starting to design
an ld array which is mainly due to the
fact that we want to increase the
sample throughput per week
because this ld array is genotyped in
386 format
we have been submitting the array in
july
and now we are running and we're running
the validation
steps quite similar to what we have been
what i have been showing in this talk
uh thank you for your attention and
thank you uh to all the colleagues who
have
been doing any contribution to this
talk
and i'm happy to take any questions